all right tonight sadly anti-Semitism it
is on the rise Democrats they seem not
quite as sure how to respond on Thursday
the very first day of Hanukkah a man
shouting free Palestine literally fired
a shotgun outside of a temple now this
as many on the left are voicing public
support for a global Islamic war or what
they call antaa and other left-wing
demonstrators now openly condoning what
the rape the murder the torture of
October the 7th praising Hamas for
confronting their quote oppressors by
any means necessary earlier in the week
we had the presidents of havid and MIT
and upen they refused to condemn calls
for genocide without more context and
get this the executive director of the
group care that's the Council on
American Islamic relations recently
praising the October 7th Massacre
proclaiming that Israel has no right to
self-defense really take a look the
people of
Gaza only decided to break the
siege the walls of the concentration
camp on October 7th and yes I was happy
to see people breaking the siege and
throwing down the shackles of their own
land and walk free into their lands that
they were not allowed to walk in
and yes the people of Gaza have the
right to
self-defense all right and get this it
gets way worse the Biden Administration
they were coordinating with care in an
official capacity to quote combat
anti-Semitism now since those despicable
and repulsive comments the White House
has been frantically trying to distance
itself from uh care and scrubbing any
mention of the group from the White
House website and both the vice
president and the second gentleman have
also recently condemned anti-Semitism
frankly after weeks of Silence here with
reaction Fox News contributor Jason
chaitz and best-selling author and
former special Envoy for combating
anti-terrorism Noah tishby is with us
Noah your reaction to
this my reaction is that we're very
pleased that care was removed from the
White House website when anything that
has to do with with anti-semitism
the fact of the matter is this care has
had a history of let's say questionable
remarks when it comes to the Jewish
people and they should not have been a
part of the anti-Semitism strategy of
the White House one of their uh San
Francisco chairs said a couple of years
ago that we have to be careful of the
zionists organizations what we're seeing
here is the truth coming out the fact of
the matter is this all these
organizations do not want Israel to
exist they're trying to wipe Israel off
the map and they're trying to do this in
a very convoluted and kind of like
hidden way we've been saying for a very
long time that anti-Semitism and
anti-zionism are one and the same and
this is exactly what we're seeing right
now the truth is coming out they don't
want Israel to exist and we need to
fight this I want to say one more thing
about that uh nihad aad okay he was
talking about Gaz and people owning uh
walking on their land they are denying
Jewish Nativity and Ingenuity in the
land of Israel which is absolutely
ridiculous we're about to celebrate the
birthday of a Jewish man who lived in
Nazareth over 2,000 years ago and
they're trying to tell us that Jews have
not been in Israel since before 1948
this is absolutely ridiculous I'm very
happy that that organization was removed
from anything that has to do with the
White House strategy on anti-Semitism
what what do you make Jason of the Biden
Administration embracing the group CARE
we know their history why why would they
do
that I I I there's no justification and
they're not the only ones the interns
and the other people and the staff in
the White House have also been
problematic you know Adolf Hitler killed
millions of Jews and he slaughtered uh
millions of ethnic minorities and he did
it with the justification that he needed
this genocide to help cleanse the Earth
and yet Hamas takes the same position
and these University professors care and
others say that well you just have to
put it in context and and so they went
out and slaughtered another 1,300 people
and then they say that proudly and they
think that the people of Harvard and the
students of Harvard that that's not a
hate crime or that's not threatening or
intimidating to go out and say you know
we really should carry on because what
they are advocating for is exactly what
was advocated for by Adolf Hitler they
claim the same types of things and I
they they should be just absolutely they
got to deport the people that are here
that are are guests of the United States
and they got to get serious about
cleaning this up but the White House
it's it's embarrassment can't allow it
to happen for sure no thank you great to
see you and Jason always good to have
you thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else